doing a fantastic job at the Army Corps
if we have interesting construction talk
don't we really great stuff president of
the National Border Patrol Council
Brendan Judd hello Brendan what are you
doing sitting back I've never seen that
before
you're always up here with me you're
getting low-key lately huh that's
confidence that means he's got a lot of
confidence that's great and thank you
for everything Brendan and say hello to
everybody great job you do appreciate it
it was a supporter of mine before I ran
he said I hope that guy runs right so I
appreciate it very much we won't forget
idea there and several other very
dedicated and heroic members of law
enforcement I met just a few of them
back there and they gave me a a
beautiful replica of the wall a little
shorter version but that's okay and we
want to thank everybody we're also
joined by some of my very good friends
and people have great respect for you
have a great governor in this state and
has been a great friend for the state
but he's been a great friend to our
nation and does it just a great job Doug
duecy thank you very much appreciate it
talk to you in a little while appreciate
it
senator martha mcsalley who I hear is
doing very well we need you in
Washington will you please win because
we need you the alternative that's
running against you is not the person
that we want
we've got he's got things that we don't
want so if we want you to win this race
is very important and we appreciate all
the help that you've given us especially
on the border wall we appreciate it
Martha
thank you very much representative
Debbie Lesko has become a tremendous
friend of mine and supporter and with
the impeachment hoax
she was right up front and it was good
for you you became very famous I became
more famous and you became very very
famous right well it certainly didn't
hurt she was one of the really great
advocates who's terrific we appreciate
it Debbie thank you Yuma mayor Douglas
Nichols and Thank You Douglas very much
for being here
welcome back to back to you mom thank
you very much really an honor and Yuma
police chief Susan Smith Thank You Susan
very much for being here so my
administration has done more than any
Administration in history to secure our
southern border our border has never
been more secure I think Doug can tell
you that anybody at this table can tell
you that it's never even been close the
numbers now including not only the wall
the wall has helped a lot where we have
that 200 miles to 12 and now to 20 it's
really essentially almost I guess
ninety-nine point six or something like
that maybe somebody can get an
extraordinarily long ladder but once you
get up there it gets very high and it's
just about unclimbed well so it's a it's
really great that's made a big
difference but we have other things that
we've done during the past two months
we've seen the lowest number of illegal
border crossings in many years illegal
immigration is down 84% from this time
last year illegal crossings from Central
America are down 97% now the news that
once they fake news I want to be nice
today so the news will say 97% Doug
that's not very good but 97% I would say
sounds pretty good you sure it's 97
right yeah that's a pretty good that's a
pretty good number you're doing 97
percent down nearly 450,000 pounds of
drugs have been seized this year and
2337 criminal aliens have been
apprehended we've stopped Asylum fraud
ended catch and release if you look at
so many of the different crimes that
come through the border they're stopped
we've implemented groundbreaking
agreements with Mexico I want to thank
the President of Mexico is really a
great guy I think he'll be coming into
Washington pretty soon to the White
House but they have a total of what's
the number today would you say soldiers
what would you say
over 20 so we've had 27,000 28,000
25,000 Mexican soldiers are on our
border makin sure people aren't coming
of course I want to also say that we've
made a lot of progress with Guatemala El
Salvador and Honduras and now when
somebody comes over whether it's ms-13
or anybody else we bring them back and
they take them gladly in the previous
administration they didn't take him at
all they wouldn't take him they said you
keep using our emergency public health
authorities we prevented a coronavirus
catastrophe on the southern border
shutting down human smuggling and
swiftly returning the crosses we call
them crosses they crossed now we bring
them right back in the old days it would
take years to get him back he wouldn't
get him back other administration's like
the previous administration essentially
didn't bring them back without these
public health measures the southern
border would be a global epicenter of
the viral transmission and if you look
at some of the towns on the other side
of the wall as an example in California
we have a certain area that is heavily
infected on the Mexico side and if we
didn't have a border wall there it would
be a it would be really a catastrophic
situation so I just want to thank
everyone the Biden people and he's
controlled totally by the radical left
as you understand he's not controlling
it they're controlling him they want
open borders they want criminal
sanctuaries they want everything that
doesn't work I don't even think it works
politically frankly at this point people
see what happened you'll take a look at
what's happening in Seattle or take a
look Minnesota is such a great great
state but you look at Minneapolis and
you see what happened there until we
sent in we sent in the National Guard we
said you got to do it as soon as they
were there boom shut down all the
problems they had shut down you didn't
hear about them anymore and many other
places last night in Washington we heard
they were going to take down the statue
Washington DC the statue of Andrew
Jackson a beautiful statue in Lafayette
Park
and Mark Meadows is here he heard about
it I heard about it we sent people there
and law enforcement did an incredible
job they ran into that place and we were
minutes away
there was a sneak attack and now we've
enacted an act very specific statue and
monument act that puts people in jail
for 10 years if they do anything to even
try to deface one of our monuments or
statues so we have numerous people in
prison right now others are going there
and we're going to look at that from a
standpoint of retroactivity we can go
back and look at some of the damage
they've done but largely it's state
damage because the states have been very
weak extremely weak in protecting their
heritage and protecting their culture so
the states are gonna have to take care
of themselves but we're there to help if
they want with Ledley help but the
federal statues monuments buildings
various things that we have including if
you look at the Jefferson Memorial at
the Lincoln Memorial they want to take
down George Washington how about that
one that's a new one
we heard that the other day George
Washington I don't think will let that
happen Doug right I don't think we're
gonna let that happen but George
Washington and so many others say I
really don't even think frankly they
know who they're taking down I think
they just want to do things for bad
purposes so and these aren't protestors
these are agitators and others so we've
taken a very strong stance and it won't
be happening federally if it does
they're going to pay a very big price
and they know that it won't be happening
with the federal statues and monuments
so with that I'd like to just introduce
Jed Wolfe to say a few words about the
border the job we've done on general
security not just the southern border
the southern border has been a primary
focus as everyone knows because
tremendous amounts of drugs and other
things come down human trafficking we
have that down to the lowest number
we've had in many years and again being
helped a lot by the length of our
all which is gonna be complete very soon
so Chad say a few words please
well Thank You mr. president and we're
here today as a testament to your
leadership and determination to secure
our nation's borders in recent weeks as
you've mentioned our country has
witnessed an all-out attack against our
law enforcement thankfully you have not
stood idly by instead you're supporting
the brave law enforcement officers who
sacrifice so much for all of us every
day and nowhere is that support as
important as it is here at the southwest
border border security is homeland
security the first priority of any
nation is to ensure the sovereignty by
protecting the integrity of its borders
mr. president you have disregarded the
ineffective conventional wisdom put
forth by folks in DC and instead listen
to your operators and they have been
very clear they want an effective and
lasting border wall system and you've
been you've responded by making
available over 15 billion dollars to
fund this critical capability so your
support of the men and women of DHS and
CBP are is beyond comparison others such
as general Semin it--and Commissioner
Morgan will talk to you about the
attributes of the wall but let me just
focus on a few key issues that you also
brought up that goes into securing our
borders not only the border wall system
but we are also closing loopholes that
have served as magnets over the last
three years
enticing migrants to take a very
dangerous journey north to the US and
entered our country illegally we have
entered into a number of game-changing
agreements with our northern triangle
partners to stem the flow of the illegal
migrants as well we've demanded you
specifically have demanded Mexico step
up their efforts and we're seeing more
and more migrants being turned around at
Mexico's southern border before they
reach our own we're also addressing
abuse as you mentioned of the asylum
system clamping down on the use of
frivolous asylum claims to illegally
obtain work authorization here in the US
we're also disrupting and dismantling
dangerous cartels by leveraging the
unique capabilities of the United States
Coast Guard as well as the United States
Navy we're attacking these are criminals
where they're most vulnerable and that's
at the sea and perhaps most importantly
you took decisive action to restrict
travel to the US during Kovan 19
and you've taken recent action to put
American workers first as we reopen the
economy
so mr. president want to thank you once
again for your support of the men and
women of DHS also for your support of
law enforcement across the country but
particularly here along the southwest
border we look forward to continuing our
work on the border wall system and
making the border even more secure first
came it was a thing called a caravan and
you'd have caravans you'd have these
massive amounts of people coming up and
they'd be coming from sometimes Honduras
or Guatemala El Salvador other countries
they come through those countries
sometimes but thousands and thousands of
people I guess the largest one we saw is
maybe 15,000 that's a lot of people very
dangerous for those people two things
that happened on that journey up were
brutal and it was a long journey but we
don't have that anymore because they
know they can't get through and when
they know they can't get through they
don't want to go through that so you
know we've told other countries you
can't do that can't have caravans and
they listen to us so it was a big it's a
big difference right now tremendous
difference mark please
yes sir so couple things first I want to
echo what the secretary said sir I want
to say as a commissioner CBP thank you
thank you from early on you listened
where others before you had not I think
Brandon judge could testify to that
early on right brandy was engaging you
and you engaged the experts who are on
the front lines every day risking their
lives for this country and you asked
them what do you need and one of the
things they said is we need an effective
border wolf system and mr. president you
have delivered that and to echo what the
secretary said too we also concur that
border security is national security
it's just common sense we have to know
who and what is coming through our
borders and to our borders then we have
to be able to defend that and with every
new mile of new wall system the
operational capacity of CBP specifically
the border patrol is increased our
ability to enforce the rule of law has
increased our ability to maintain
integrity the immigration system has
increased our ability
to improve border security has increased
and our ability to shape and drive the
hate behavior of the cartels has also
increased our ability to to impede deny
and stop that the vast threats that we
have have increased because of your
leadership and provide us the tools like
the wall system and I think this is also
important and we we've talked about this
before it's not just a wall I keep
saying wall system on purpose because
what you have delivered is something
that has not been delivered before it's
not just a bunch of steel on the ground
it's a that plus access roads technology
other attributes that really makes it an
effective wall system and gives us an
ability that we have not had before and
that's why I stay true to the fact when
I'm asked the 220 miles of wall system
we have in right now are 220 new miles
of wall system that gives us an enhanced
capability that we never had
stopping drugs at the border that's what
we should do that that helps reduce the
tens of thousands of American citizens
have died every years at the hands of
the cartels smuggling drugs across this
border stopping human smuggling at the
border prevents and reduces the ability
of women children to be lost abandoned
and further exploited by the cartels
stopping criminals and gangs at the
border reduces violent crime in every
city in this country stopping infectious
disease like Ovid 19 at the border has
saved countless lives and that is due to
your leadership and that's why we say
all the time that every town city and
state is a border town border city
border state everything that touches our
border touches every city town and state
in this country and that's why we have
said and we will continue to say borders
Madol matter the wall matters and I want
to end by saying the special thanks also
to general Todd Semin aight it's been an
incredible relationship that we've had
his wall team as we call it and CBP's
wall team we've worked together for the
past few years and making this happen
and I am 100% convinced
that we will reach about 450 miles by
the end of the calendar year
first of all thanks for having us in in
the Corps of Engineers is exceptionally
honored to work on one of these largest
infrastructure projects in our country
and the Commissioner talked about the
team I mean it goes to the secretary
wolf all the CBP agents phenomenal
people we could do this alone and it's
just a very noble calling to be able to
put this in place just to be able to
talk to you a little bit again this is a
fourth state program about 15 billion
dollars 49 different projects that are
being done right now and I'm just going
to give you a quick couple numbers here
there are 220 miles that are complete
they're done we're doing about a mile a
day right now under contract right now
being built put in the ground steel in
concrete 384 miles and then we've got
another 129 miles that are actually
we're working through real estate we're
working through the design and we
continue to get all that in so that
would be somewhere over 700 miles that's
already under under work and being done
that's a hundred and there's a hundred
and forty-four thousand panels that are
being put in the ground these are 8 feet
wide 30 or 18 feet high already in place
in concrete so it's a pretty massive
system today we're actually looking at
what we call the Yuma primary this is 26
miles cost about 267 million dollars
51 thousand cubic yards of concrete
about 36,000 tons of steel and sir what
we've got in this particular project
about 17,000 panels so a lot going on
there and I just went in by looking at
the elected officials of Arizona and it
goes to the other states as well a CBP
are the Corps of Engineers were
absolutely committed to do this where it
is in its environmentally less impact as
possible we want to put as many jobs as
we can into the local community we want
to continue to make sure that we are
doing we're going overboard on kovin
compliance right now our contractors
have some of the most stringent measures
in America before to make sure before
they ever walk on the work space they're
being as safe as they absolutely can and
if there's anything else that we need to
do to be able to make sure we're in very
very close with with your constituents
we are committed to do that so sir we're
honored to be here and we got a lot of
great things going on thank you very
much Brandon could I ask you to say a
few words because you were the ones that
said you you told me we need a wall
you got to get the wall Oh first
president actions speak much louder than
words you are the only present in my 20
year 23 year career that has actually
come down to the more of multiple times
to look at and assess what actually
needs to be done your agents I normally
call them my agents but they are your
agents your agents appreciate the fact
that you've gone above and beyond well
more than any other president in the
history of my career your agents want
two things they want border security
which is security for the entire United
States and they want economic security
for their family for their friends and
for their loved ones you built the
strongest economy in my lifetime we
trust that you're going to continue to
build that economy pandemic it nobody
saw it coming
nobody could have predicted it you will
build that economy and we trust that you
will do build that economy you've done
more to secure the border we are at
historic lows and you've done it twice
not just once none of your predecessors
were able to do that you've talked with
the men and women of the border show
you've invited me to the Oval Office on
multiple occasions consult with what the
boots on the ground want they have
consistently told you walls in strategic
locations who work it allows us to
dictate where traffic goes it allows us
to be a lot more effective you not your
predecessors have done that you built
the economy you have provided border
security and you continue to do it and
we continue to look forward to work with
you
Thank You Brandon
it's very interesting because Brendon
was telling me right at the beginning we
needed the wall and what kind of wall we
need and you have to have a vision
through the wall if you don't have the
vision through and then we we met and
you all agreed but we met with your
people we had various design
competitions for I said if we're gonna
build it let's build it right and we had
design competitions the world that was
hardest to get over the wall that was
impossible to climb or certainly very
very hard and this was the hardest and
we built the top of the line but you
were really great up Thank You Brendan
very much so a man that's been so much
as just done a great job for the area
and very is is so into security of the
state of this great state of Arizona and
I just think he's really a fantastic the
governor could you say a few words
please one welcome back to Arizona mr.
president it's good to have you here and
I want to say to be down on the border
for years Arizonans have heard empty
talk about the border and this is the
first administration that has taken
action so I want to say how grateful I
am for the partnership with Homeland
Security how your Border Patrol your
Customs and Border Protection and ice
have all been helpful the Army Corps of
Engineers not only what they're doing on
the wall but what they're doing for
potential surge capacity around Co vat19
I think shows the best of what's
possible when there's a partnership
between the federal government and the
state government and it's been your
leadership that is allowed there to be
real action and in 2014 when I was first
elected there were large areas of
Arizona's border that were wide open and
unprotected and on this 220 mile stretch
now there is border security which is
national security and that will stop
drug cartels human traffickers and child
sex traffickers and and your top folks
have partnered with the border strike
force in Arizona and as a result we've
kept
kept dangerous drugs and this poison out
of our schools and neighborhoods as well
as protecting people who are not being
trafficked over the border so I'm
grateful and I know there's more to do
because the border is longer than 220
miles I look forward to working with you
in the coming years to complete the job
mostly complete by the end of the year
and there may be a little we may add a
little and then we may find spots where
we want to add that we'll have
everything we wanted pretty much by the
end of the year that's great thank you
great job you're doing and Martha is
there and you've been such a help and I
appreciate it and I know how you feel
about border security maybe better than
anybody but I just want to thank you for
your help please say welcome back to
Arizona it was an honor to fly with you
on Air Force One and bring you back for
this commemoration I feel like we were
just here recently for the hundredth
mile and so it just shows with the
partnership that's been talked about
here how quickly you've been able to
enact this border wall system to give
the agents everything that they need in
order to secure our border and I know
our mayor note knows the impact of that
on this community and in the sector
chief here border security is national
security it's also health security I
think people have realized now in this
pandemic that borders matter and they
matter for the safety and security of
this state and the whole nation and the
drugs that have been flowing through
easily that are impacting and killing
loved ones around America it has to stop
and this border wall system is a huge
part of stopping the cartel activity
stopping that poison from coming across
and giving these agents everything they
need as we support law enforcement for
everything they do in order to keep us
safe at the federal and at the local
level so thanks for your leadership and
your partnership on this and welcome
back to Arizona thank you very much
thanks Martha great job
appreciate it come on let's go you can
do it again you know I'm I'm on the
ground I'm on Judiciary Committee and
homeland security committees so I see
firsthand how many of my Democratic
colleagues really want to prioritize
illegal immigrant
/ US citizens and they really do want
open borders I mean I don't understand
it but they do and so there's such a
clear difference between you and your
future opponent in this issue and
Democrats [ __ ] I mean I sat in
Judiciary Committee when Chairman Jerry
Nadler said that the border patrol
officers were guilty of child abuse and
I think they said to mr. Morgan that he
was guilty of negligent homicide I mean
the insanity of what they're saying and
the difference is so clear between what
the Democrats want for the future of our
nation and what you are doing to make us
safe and make our country safe and I
want to thank you for that well I think
one of the all-time classics and I'm
sure you all remember it well was they
had a picture of a cage in the New York
Times and other places and it was a cage
for children and they said president
Trump built it and how horrible it was
and they still talk about it even though
they know it's not true and somebody
wrote in no no that cage was built in
2014 by President Obama I guess you
could say Biden but I don't think Biden
knew too much about it frankly it still
does it but it was built by President
Obama and Mark called it was around this
business for a long time he said that
wasn't built by President Trump that was
built by President Obama in 2014 they
gave me an exact date actually they gave
me the date it was constructed meaning a
series of cages and I've sort of never
forgot that and they still say that you
know they still take it take that same
picture that's where they get called the
faked is that it's too bad because they
oughta straighten it out it would be so
good for our country but you know that
was built in 2014 I never forgot it
somehow I never forgot it
anyway mr. mayor would you like to say
something thank you very much mr.
president and thanks again for coming
back to Yuma but thank you more
importantly for last year when you
helped us through a big surge of the
Central American families with the folks
with DHS
they stepped up and addressed the very
specific concern we had now if you fast
forwarded that situation to today and
those families were coming through with
kovat that would be 5200 people coming
through my community potentially with
kovat so the wall
it's simple math the wall prevents
people from coming that prevents the
number of exposures we can have to cope
it so from local perspective that that
helps our community but the men and
women of PHS that live here there are
residents there are fan friends there
are family members and it's very
personal and very poignant fact for us
to have those kind of protections in
place so thank you very much on the
other side of San Diego is a
tremendously big problem with covent and
other things and they wanted that wall
so badly you know you don't hear this
about California they wanted that wall
they were calling everybody was cool I
wouldn't even tell I wouldn't embarrass
them by saying who called but people
that didn't want the wall outside one of
the wall and I built the wall and it
worked a hundred percent you know what
I'm talking about and then I see one of
the politicians two weeks later they
should take down the wall by the way it
works so well but he was saying they
should have taken down the wall but now
they don't even say that because now it
stopped kovat it stopped everything it
stopped the whole deal and you've had it
and you see the experience and we're
going to take a good look at a big chunk
that we have right in your backyard
right here and I know it's made a big
difference for you man that's great
you've done a fantastic job thank you
very much chief would you like to say
something and I really first want to
thank you very much for your support of
law enforcement local and federal it's
much needed right now
and it's appreciated I can tell you I
worked on the road back in the early
2000s and I understand firsthand the
calls for service related to
undocumented immigrants and how high
those calls for service were and then
after the border enhancement security
measures were put into place I can tell
you that we saw a marked decline in many
of those costs those
crimes associated with undocumented
immigrants such as load vehicles coming
across with drugs and humans human
trafficking is stolen vehicles and other
crimes related so it's very much
appreciated and it is helped with the
security in Yuma County one thing I want
you to take away is that Yuma County is
a very unique community in that all of
the law-enforcement work very
collaborative collaboratively together
from our federal state and local
partners so I hope you get that takeaway
when you leave here thank you very much
pushing I look forward to seeing it
please we first told you about China and
fentanyl coming in from over there
you took decisive action in you held
China accountable we explained about
South America and drugs coming up
through the Caribbean and you had
secretary Esper do a surge out at sea to
prevent the boats from bringing the
drugs into our country and as we're
talking about today when we talked about
the southwest border you already knew it
but you knew to took action and you did
it and you are now taking tough stance
here at the southwest border we talked
about treatment we talked about the need
to make sure that people get help you
committed more funds than any other
president in history you also talked
about the importance of preventing kids
from going down this path on prevention
you committed more funds than any other
president in history and you did
everything with one purpose in mind and
that is to save more American lives and
you have done it for 30 years
drug deaths were going up last year
prior to covet first time in three
decades the number of Americans dying
from a drug overdose went down and
that's because of all the action you
have taken on treatment prevention and
stopping drugs from coming into our
country and killing our children it's
been a great honor to be able to work
for you in this capacity and see your
passion for saving American lives
appreciate that very much we are working
very hard on it so appreciate doing a
great job
thank you please mr. president thank you
for visiting Yuma sector Border Patrol
the the agents here the men and women of
this sector have put in tireless days
the past several years in the recent
surge across the southwest border here
in this sector even though even though
you might as a small sector the second
smallest sector on the southwest border
in less than 800 agents here in this
sector even though that is the case we
were the third busiest sector on the
southwest border and what that looked
like here is in 2017 we had over 12,000
apprehensions which was more than a
hundred percent increase one year later
in 2018 we had 26,000 again another
hundred percent increase one year after
that last year 2019 over 68,000
apprehensions here and it takes a while
for the government for leadership
represented here today for the members
the elected officials here today it
takes a while for those resources to
flow in and the agents we we know
they're coming we believe they're coming
but now we know it we see it on the
ground we see what flew in here over the
past year to help us out when we were in
in dire straits in this sector we did
not have the capacity we needed
facilities wise we did not have the
resources we needed but the agents
really fought through that drove through
that and they did what was right because
every single person that was coming over
here even though yes they broke the law
they still had to be taken care of why
they were in our custody we still had to
step up and get that part done and to do
that we leveraged state officials we
leverage the local community you know we
leverage NGOs in the area to help us but
now you know thank you for your
leadership because now those resources
have arrived and now in this sector
we're receiving a hundred and ten miles
of new wall system and out there right
now today is more than 60 miles already
built already completed and that 60
miles makes a huge difference every
single mile of new wall system that is
put in and every single mile
both both illegal entries in that
particular area drug smuggling in that
particular area border crime in that
particular area has decreased in every
single mile that new wall system gets
put in and I thank you for the
leadership I thank everybody at the
table today for leadership around the
room in order to take on this particular
effort and help Yuma sector border
patrol and doing what we need to do to
help secure the United States so thank
you very much very much those are
incredible numbers and I just want to
say this is one of the most difficult
things I've ever had to do because we
had a raised you know large amount of
money as you were saying this was one of
the biggest projects you've ever worked
on it's a tremendous you know here it's
a wall but it's a wall that's very big
it very long and very powerful and the
Democrats didn't want to do it they just
didn't want to do it Doug no matter what
it didn't matter and these are people
that voted in favor of it ten years ago
but they never got it built because they
didn't know how to build it because that
building it is tough too but I do that
and we don't have build but they tried
to block it they did everything in their
power to block it and it's very
interesting because in the end it sort
of just went through and the military
helped us and we're getting it built
regardless but they don't like bringing
it up and it's never mentioned anymore
the wall has never mentioned any more
the reason it's not mentioned it's not
that we won the battle it's that it's
such a compelling thing to have done
because you see the numbers and where
that wall is going as you're saying it's
like it's like magic you don't have to
do saves tremendous manpower and woman
power
saves tremendous human resources and
saves lives but they want open borders
and they don't want walls and they
fought harder than anybody I've ever
seen and in the end they quit they gave
up the reason they gave up because
politically it's unacceptable to say
especially with this new disease coming
in the pandemic the new disease coming
in a gift from China
especially when that happened and they
say how can we be putting this so they
don't want to talk about the wall
anymore they opposed it they were
strongly opposed to it and it was
interesting because you said about the
wall they'd say no no we don't need a
wall we can have airplanes flying above
we could have people taking pictures we
can have drones they wanted drones I
said what are you going to take pictures
of everyone flowing across they didn't
want to say they said no no walls
that's old technology no walls of the
greatest technology - what I said I sort
of came up with this I'm sure somebody
did before I said there's two things
because everything changes in the world
they changed fast change is so fast you
do a computer and it's obsolete in two
weeks but two things that have never
changed a wall and a wheel we're going
to always have wheels and we're going to
always have walls and we have the best
security wall ever built and we'll have
a completed very soon and the way you
said that was very nice I appreciate it
the big difference that it's been it's
it's really great thank you very much
thank you
so we're going to the wall now and we're
gonna see a piece of the wall we're not
going to be able to cover 500 miles of
view but we'll be able to cover about
ten yards but we'll see a piece of a
long of a long wall that we're building
and you'll see you'll see what we're
talking about we'll see you over there
thank you media thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]
oh do do sexo Leo can't hunt a lion a
particle or even a mother base